a new iOS 17 update just launched and
this is actually a pretty significant
launch we now have access to the new
journal app and the ability to shoot
spatial video on your iPhone 15 Pros now
with this spatial video this will be
giving you the ability to use this
content and have it be viewed in Vision
Pro and if you don't know what that is
it's Apple's headset that is due to
launch sometime next year and I could
not be more excited mostly because I did
get a chance to try it out again
recently and I'm not going to lie it was
even more impressive the second and
third time around so after you do this
latest update go into your camera
settings into formats scroll down to the
bottom and you'll see video capture
spatial video for Apple Vision Pro now
with this on you'll then go into your
camera and you'll see that when we
switch to video this now gives us a
little goggles symbol right here so when
we press this it'll say move further
away and it'll make sure that your
camera is set up to be filming
horizontally and this is using the two
lenses side by side on your iPhone to
shoot the spatial video here it is I'm
currently in my office filming a video
right now I'm spinning around and you
can see I've got all sorts of Lights set
up and this is what it looks like and
there's just a lot of stuff over there
we don't even we just won't even
bother this is a boy come here oh look
at this good Dogg who's the best boy in
the whole
world
Maddie here's the Journal welcome to
journal write about your day you can add
photos places and more you can lock it
to keep it private and you can schedule
a time for writing to make it a habit
the cool thing about the journal is it
will give you prompts I've never been
one to keep a journal so I am kind of
excited to try this out so to start it
says it uses on device intelligence to
create journaling suggestions based on
your everyday moments so we're going to
turn on our journaling suggestions get
notified when it's time to write your
Journal you'll set the schedule and I'm
going to journal let's do it every day
why not start journaling so I like that
this gives me some options for things so
I was at the game awards not too long
ago so let's write a little Journal
about this so fun so this pulls up
addresses nearby I can also do a voice
memo I had so much fun at the game
awards it was the best time ever okay
bye we can take photos add photos and
there it is my first journal entry this
will also give you prompts so here's one
who is someone who can always make you
laugh out loud all right let's say Jenna
that's my sister not the best entry but
you know if I want do this every day
even if it is a small entry it's still
something this is also something that I
like is you're able to bring in workouts
because my plan originally was how cool
would that to be to use journal for
tracking workouts there's no Jiu-Jitsu
in Aura ring so I have to just Market as
wrestling I worked on open guard passing
Concepts can also lock your Journal add
a passcode or face ID we're turning that
on you can also sort your Journal
entries by photos videos recorded audio
activity and Reflections what do you
guys think of the new Journal appb